Este es un tanque de leopardo es el
motivo de la presión que cae sobre
Alemania respecto a las próximas ayudas
militares a Ucrania luego de que el
gobierno aclarara que el envío de los
leopard no está vinculado a la entrega
de los abrams estadounidenses en la
reunión de los aliados en Rammstein no
se llegó a un acuerdo al respecto
en la mañana el ministro de defensa
alemán negó que Berlín bloqueara el
suministro unilateralmente
Es que
muchos aliados dicen que comparten los
puntos de vista que presenté nuevamente
aquí Hoy hay buenas razones para una
entrega y hay buenas razones en contra y
a la luz de la situación general de la
guerra que ya ha durado casi un año
todos los pros y contras deben sopesarse
con mucho cuidado
por ahora Berlín ordenó revisar las
existencias y la disponibilidad de sus
tanques el secretario general de la otan
James stoltenberg remarcó este viernes
el rol que Alemania ha tenido en la
defensa de Ucrania sin embargo Desde que
reiteraron la urgencia
tenemos que acelerar el tiempo debe
convertirse en nuestra arma común al
igual que la defensa aérea y la
artillería los vehículos blindados y los
tanques que estamos negociando con
ustedes que realmente lograrán la
victoria
en Rusia advirtieron que la utilización
de tanques de occidente solamente traerá
más daño para Ucrania
las consecuencias serán inequívocamente
negativas hemos dicho repetidamente que
tales suministros no podrán cambiar nada
fundamentalmente pero agregarán
problemas para Ucrania y para el pueblo
ucraniano
los especialistas son muy conscientes de
los problemas que acompañan a tales
entregas todos estos tanques necesitan
tanto mantenimiento como reparación
a pesar de que selenky remarcó que el
tiempo es un arma rusa Alemania ratificó
que evaluarán las condiciones y que la
voluntad por mantener el equilibrio en
Europa no está en discusión